We're going to introduce today, iPad 2.
The second generation iPad.
So, what is iPad 2?
What have we learned?
What can we improve?
Well, it is an all new design.
It is not a tweaked design.
It's not got marginal improvements.
It's a completely new design.
And the first thing is, it's dramatically faster.
We have a new chip we call A5.
Our chip wizards have come up with this and it's great.
It's a dual-core processor.
Alright, two processors inside and so, we get up to twice as fast on CPU performance.
But we've really gone all out on the graphics performance,...
...up to nine times faster graphics.
The graphics in this thing are wonderful.
The same low power as A4.
We don't wanna give up any of that legendary battery life.
And even though others are starting to ship,...
...I think this is gonna be the first dual-core tablet to ship in volume.
So, A5 is really quite an achievement.
And is gonna give us something that's up to twice as fast on CPU performance,...
...up to nine times faster on graphics.
And the first iPad was no slouch.
So, a lot faster with A5.
Second, we built in some cameras for video.
We've got a rear camera out the back and we've got a front-facing camera out the front.
We'll talk more about that in a few minutes.
We've also built in the gyroscope that we have in the iPhone and the iPod Touch.